[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one bestselling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
and host of the Ken Coleman show is my
co-host today open phones as we take
your questions about your life and your
money open phones at
88255 225 James is in Appleton Wisconsin
starting this hour off hi James how are
you I'm good how are you doing Dave
better than I deserve what's up awesome
so I have a question for you in regards
of scaling my full-time gig into like an
entrepreneurial situation where I work
for myself and no longer for a company
you mean your part-time gate correct
okay and how do you quit your full-time
job is that what you're saying exactly
okay I got confused okay I'm with you
all right all right so a little bit of
background um at this point with my
full-time gig my wife's income and the
side gig I I make about 360 to 375,000 a
year in annual
income um and we completed all the baby
steps um unfortunately we did fall back
into baby step 6B and we do own a second
home um at this point um as a lake house
and that is on Pace to be paid off at
5,000 a month um by
2030 and currently one of the ways that
we're really being aggressive and paying
this off is with my side gig um where I
buy and resell video
games um at this point just as a side
gig I have about 200,000 a year of
Revenue at
85% net
margin and really just looking at ways
to really grow and build that so that I
could maybe step into that at some point
in time where I need to back up cuz I I
got lost in a number there the 375 is
that your personal income at your day
job or is that household income that's
all household income from all income
sources so my what is your day job job
what do you get paid on your day
job uh about 230,000 a year give or take
with bonus okay so you would walk away
from that for something that is
currently making 85% margin on
200k correct so about 170 all
right so 230 for
170 how much you on this
Lakehouse about 400 geez nice Lakehouse
mm now you said you're what are you
paying yourself off of the side hustle I
know what it's bringing in is that what
you're paying yourself the 170ish I I
end up paying myself about 80 885,000 a
year okay so how much is your wife
making um 60,000 okay so there we got
the breakdown so 290 between your day
job and her day job correct okay well do
you know how you're going to scale this
I you've done a good job getting it up
to I didn't know you know buying and
reselling video games to get it to that
point of about 200 gross income what is
the next phase to scale that are you
aware of that or still trying to figure
that out well I'm kind of trying to
figure that out so in my mind I have a
way that I could go big um but it would
require about $2 million of investment
and that's just something where I'm not
in a spot where I'm G to go into debt
for or anything like that I agree with
that it sounds like a bad idea not an
option well the simple answer to this is
when anybody asks us this question the
simple answer is well we want to get you
to a point where you are replacing your
day job income with the side hustle and
I always like to go a step further and
have about 6 months of that income and
retain earnings in the side hustle bank
account so that's the simple kind of on
paper because that removes all risk and
it doesn't put stress on this side
hustle which is ultimately this thing
you really want to do and so that's a
good emotional and financial decision um
so that's the straightforward answer but
you've been debt free and all of a
sudden you got the Lakehouse and so I
think it's going to be a while it would
be my answer before I go full-time what
do you what do you do that makes
230 um I'm a Director of Finance for an
S&P 500 company okay all right
so here's the tradeoff um you've got to
have
a way that you can see the thing scaling
that's not $2
million because you know you don't want
to you don't want to quit your job and
be stuck at 85% of
200 right correct uh so what do we got
to do to not take this thing to the moon
but to just double
it
correct and I'm asking do you have any
idea any idea how to do a smaller scale
than a $2 million investment um so
really at this point I do have one
employee that does all my packing and
unpacking for me and some of my quality
checks um I have debated in terms of
scaling it just basically doubling my
inventory I never have more than five
or6 thousand of inventory on hand oh you
can double your inventory but only if
you can double your
sales correct is inventory limitation
limiting
sales um no it's time and investment I
maybe spend 5 to 10 hours a week on this
at this point so that's what I would be
doing Dave I would be thinking about how
to replace himself to where now the 5 to
10 hours becomes 25 hours 30 hours and
then a full-time job so you got to
transfer your knowledge and the
experience plus the time those are the
three components of what you do in 5 to
10 hours a week yes so I I would say you
can go fulltime when you can see how to
scale this to double yeah and if it
doesn't work after you go full-time are
you willing to sell the
Lakehouse because the Lakehouse is going
to destabilize your whole freaking life
right now if you go full-time and this
thing turns
down absolutely so yeah I mean a failure
in a failure in this move could cost the
lake
[Music]
house are you willing to do that um so
you know cuz that's the risk you take
you step out of the come out of the
$230,000 Comfort gig you go for it and
it turns down you got to dump The
Lakehouse while you turn while you do
the next step right yes yeah yeah
absolutely that's what you're facing
it's a risk management issue so um yeah
that's if you're willing to do those two
things find a reasonable path to scaling
this to 400k at 85% or
80% um and find and say if it doesn't
work we we're betting The Lakehouse on
this this
dream not not the fact we're going to
get foreclosed on but I'm not going to
let the Lakehouse a toy oh 400k on take
down my life because my dream turned
left okay absolutely so you got to
manage those emotions with you and your
wife going into this if you do that
you're going to be in fine shape here
and I would tell you to go for it as
soon as you can do those two things I'll
tell you an interesting story right
quick we got just a second a guy called
me in
2012 and said I'm a farm
pharmacist and I have a side gig I make
70,000 as a pharmacist I make 70,000 on
my side gig my parents who are
pharmacists say I'm crazy to quit being
a pharmacist but I want to go do my side
gig he's doing silencers for for for
guns suppressors okay and I'm a gun guy
and so I'm like hey if you love it he
goes I love it I hate being a pharmacy I
love I don't hate it but I don't want to
be a pharmacist I I love doing this you
love this gaming stuff he was doing
70,000 that year net profit last year
did 70 million
gross I told him to quit being a
pharmacist it was good advice yeah it
was good advice and he's been successful
to this point Dave this is now about
systems and he's going to have to train
somebody to do what he does that's how
he scales us yeah the margin's there
that's what James has got to do he can
see he's got the brains to do this this
is do this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus A5 ,000
seller guarantee gives your offer the
best chance of being accepted the home
buyer Edge from Churchill gives you an
advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 thank you for joining us David
is in Kansas City hi David welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi Ken uh thank you thank
you so much for taking my call you and
your team have been such a big source of
motivation and mentorship in my life so
I appreciate you well thank you how can
we
help yeah so I've been following you I I
found you all in college and and sure I
think my my main question is so I'm 25 I
make about 990,000 a year um and I do
just want to point out like um I I am a
child of immigrants and so I I've I've
reached a good Financial uh spot being
in Babys sets four five and six but I
think thinking of 2024 uh in short I
think my biggest fear is like lifestyle
creeps and so I still live with multiple
roommates and I'm still it's still very
hard for me to you know spend money and
so I just kind of wanted to talk through
goals with you I think the next logical
goal would be to you know save up for a
house but um I do plan on maybe going
for an expat role outside of the country
in a couple years so I'm you know when I
think of the future there's a big
question mark and it's been a little bit
harder to kind of Define what it is I
want to like me my my action steps if
that makes
sense yeah that makes sense um
um so if you were to buy a home and five
years later expat what would mean you
couldn't sell the
home well I think right now I'm so uh
where I'm at right now I have around
30,000 as a down payment so I I would
want it to maybe save up a little bit
more since interest rates are so high
that wasn't my question you said I don't
need to buy a home because I may expat
in the near
future right yes so if you were to expat
in five years leave the country
expatriate right because you're you said
you're an immigrant
right I was born here in the US but my
parents are and so I I brought that up
because I think I have this mentality of
where I watch my parents sa everything
but so where would you
move uh so the company I work for we
have um uh positions all over but I
would love to go to Europe for for a
couple years that doesn't mean you need
to expath that's a whole different thing
thing xat means you're leaving and not
coming back
dude okay okay you don't want to
expatriate lose your citizenship of the
US in order to not pay taxes or deal
with the US government anymore which
that part of it sounds real appealing
but the rest of it isn't um you don't
want to lose all of that to go work for
some company in Europe and four years
later change your
mind that's not an expatriate that's I
want to work overseas different deal yes
sorry that's okay I'm not sorry it's
okay I just want to expl there's a you
know people that expatriate they move to
Costa Rica because they're never coming
home mhm it's it's the ultimate go off
the
grid thing okay that kind of stuff so
what's the timeline realistically today
you can change this he know he don't
know how old are you he has an idea I'm
25 um I'm single and I'm currently in
the middle of a ro right now so I plan
on rolling off in like July
2025 um and so you know when I'm
thinking of the next year I'm like okay
do I keep being as SLE as I can and max
out HSA max out 401k or do I kind of
take a step back and kind of like allow
I I think I mentioned this but I'm a
little nervous about lifestyle creep
because i' I've kind of seen like my
peers uh kind of you know go all out on
their apartments and their cars and so I
I don't really fall into that and so I
just I don't know if I should keep being
agressive David I think the chances of
you having lifestyle creep is close to
zero you've mentioned it three times in
the last four minutes so you're you're
not going to do that it's not it's not
inside of you okay the chances that you
um what you do need is a place something
to aim at a more defined process that
will enable you then to build your
financial plan around that and so let's
just say let's just announce to the
world we're going to move to XYZ in 2025
with my company and I want to live there
for five years okay I just made that up
or whatever if that's your announced
goal then save to make that happen and
that's not maxing out hsas that's piling
up cash in a mutual fund so you got a
big old pile of cash so while you're in
Europe or Dubai or wherever it is for 5
years working for your company you've
got some pad you've got some extra
things and then when you come home you
got a big but later 10 years from now
you've got a big old pile of cash to buy
a house
with okay okay and I guess the only
reason why I bought up the 401K and HS
for the tax advantage accounts does that
that's fine load them up but load them
up but don't do that and have no other
money you need some other money to make
some of these other to give yourself
some wiggle room in some of these other
areas so what's hurting you what's
giving you anxiety is it's difficult to
plan when there's not a set
goal and so I'm encouraging you to set a
goal even if you change it later let's
set a goal of saying I'm going to go
that's right for 5 years beginning on
this date and if it ends up being seven
years or three years so what or even if
you want a little earlier or a little
later that's fine but at least you're
planning towards that which tells you
then don't buy a house that's right
because you're going to be in Europe for
5 years you don't want a rental property
in the states when you're in or where to
buy or wherever it is you're going to go
I don't know why picked out to buy he
didn't say that but
um but that's you know that's the thing
so you can plan uh and Ken you know in
in the case of our last caller you can
plan to open a business that's right you
but you just if you if you just say
someday
yeah then you can't plan right it's like
the equivalent and and you're too young
to know this but we used to have these
things called atlases David right and so
you put them out and it was like what
you see on a phone now but a smart map
but it's the idea of just staring at it
and going well I could go here I could
go here I could go here and it's going
to drive you mad and Dave's exactly
right I know I want to go overseas so
now let's come up with our three best
options based on your company they have
locations so we start there very
specific okay these are my top three
destinations based on where my company
has offices now I'm going to look at
cost of living there so we know Portugal
is going to be way less cost of living
than Dubai if you will and that's what
Dave's talking about a very specific
strategy to go I'm going to go spend
some time here while I'm young and
single and experience life over there
what's my cost of living you know and I
can continue on my financial goals which
you already have done a great job so
this you're stressed out because you
don't have a very clear Direction
destination choose a destination then
make the financial decisions based on
the destination yeah it's a good point
and you know that that really parlays
over into a whole another discussion Ken
of some of you are facing some really
tough stuff right now
and uh my my friend uh Jim Collins wrote
a book was it thriving on chaos and I
was discussing this book with him in the
green room we were both speaking One Day
At A leadership thing and um he was so
excited about it he said I have
discovered that people uh that that
uncertainty
is much more stress
inducing than ambivalence is much more
stress inducing than a known tough road
that's correct so if you'll lay out a
road even if it's a tough road it's not
as stressful as just not knowing that's
correct yeah you know obviously the
least stress inducing is a great road
but if you've got a tough thing to do
lay it out in detail that's correct and
say these are the things I have to do to
survive this time I'm in right now and
your level of panic your level of
anxiety will drop dramatically without
question it's why the baby steps have
work for millions of people people are
freaking out my financial house is a
complete dumpster fire I don't know
where to start it's overwhelming I've
got $250,000 worth of debt and then they
begin to watch the show listen to the
show they begin to R Total Money
Makeover they begin to use every dollar
and they begin to see wait a second debt
freedom is the destination
and now I've got seven steps that I can
walk through very
clearly oh gosh hard I got to work extra
but now I know where to start I got to
live like no one else but later I get to
live and give like no one you told me a
story years ago I think you were in the
Middle East maybe been Israel and you
talked about going in a cave and you
were like I don't get freaked out by
dark and close but this was so dark
Coleman I couldn't see with a hand of
front of my face and that is the same
emotion yeah that we see in finance
relationships uh in our professional
lives when we don't know where we're
going you're paralyzed oh and even if
you're even if you are stuck yeah that
paraly that freaks you out you know
speaking of caves oh my God yeah yeah
speak glad you made it out it's being
stuck the idea that I'm stuck is is
terrifying it is I I can walk through
sewage up to my neck but just don't make
me stuck you know that's the thing right
that that's the way we all are though
and and that's that relates really to
David's situation as well the
ambivalence is more stress inducing than
the hard path yeah this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian health care Ministries a
health cost sharing Ministry but listen
to Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken colan Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
open phones atle
5225 thanks for joining us in the lobby
of ramsy Solutions on the debt free
stage Lance and Morgan are with us hey
guys how are you pretty good awesome how
are you better than I deserve serve
where do you'all live uh Evansville
Indiana Oh yeah just up the road not a
bad run to Nashville no welcome here
good to have you how much debt have you
guys paid
$168,100 good for you how long did that
take about 35 months good for you guys
and your range of income during that
three years started out around 140 and
we're going to end out the year around
one or
195,000 good for you what do you guys do
for a living um I'm a GIS technician at
a local Wastewater utility mhm and I'm a
real world signalman all right very good
you guys are doing great congratulations
thank you what kind of debts the
168 it was our mortgage you paid off
your house we did looking at a couple of
weirdos that's right I love it way to go
you two well done what's this house
worth uh around 275 wow very good and
how much have you guys got in your nest
egg already your retirement uh we're out
halfway to million
500 about another hundred in that so
you're about a half million dollar net
worth yeah way to go how old are you too
I'm 30 mhm and I'll be 30 tomorrow hey
happy birthday thank you so 30 years old
in a paid for house yall know how weird
that is right it's pretty weird pretty
weird it's pretty weird we want to be
weird that's good way to go so tell us
the story what happened 35 months ago
that made you think you could actually
do this by your 30th birthday uh we got
married in October 2020 oh wow yep good
little Co
wedding then we decided hey we might as
well tackle it hit the road running yeah
okay um prior to that I had to pay off
my student loans and he was like okay
well see you can do that so the day I
paid him off he decided to go buy the
engagement ring oh so there a
interesting
correlation
yeah so it feels a little bit longer
than 35 months for me but we decided to
go ahead and be weird we set the goal
and yeah we're able to do it knock it
out how how are you T how did you find
us radio okay yes so you were listening
on the radio and y'all are talking about
it when you're engaged or when you're
dating and then you're engaged and then
you're married so we're going to pay off
the house yeah I made her listen to it
slightly obsessed a little bit listening
to it every day oh yeah um yeah
eventually I think we just said we can
keep being gazelle and um
you know give up some boating yeah we
gave up boating two years that was a
little hard and then uh gave up
vacations we did you know many weekend
trips and some concerts we had to give
up we uh had some covid concert tickets
that had to be moved so at least we
still kind of got to enjoy that a little
bit Yeah okay all right wow so I want to
know on the other side of this you paid
the house off now and you guys went
after there's some serious sacrifice you
just mentioned but this was a lot of
effort why I want people to hear why did
it matter to you to to to sell the
excuse me to pay off the house and in
that why what does it feel like on the
other side of this did it match up with
your why the actual feeling uh yeah we
got a lot more freedom feel like now uh
the grass feels a lot Greener um it
still feels surreal seeing our checking
account you know start to increase the
first of the month you know it's not
getting the mortgage being taken out of
yeah and then off to the stage here we
got a three-month old that we just had
so we get to bring him into this world
yeah we really were trying to get him to
come to a home that was actually ours oh
wow that's great and you did I did wow
yeah so what's your first big thing
you're going to do with money now that
you're completely debt free at 30 years
old uh we got a couple vacations planned
already we got where you going uh we got
Kenny chesty concert tickets to Boston
okay always nice good run yep um we were
hoping to do Ireland as well well but
it'll probably be pushed back to 2025
mhm um but for now that's about it great
combo know we're going back boating now
next summer there there you go all right
what's that mean you buy a boat well we
always had a boat we just parked it cuz
upkeep was Al okay so it's in the
driveway we just got to activate it
that's right okay gotcha that's cool it
was a good reminder to come back yeah
yeah I'm waiting going waiting yeah good
good for you well way to go you guys way
to go what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is cuz there's
people listening going you you'll now
never have a house well you got a house
paid for and you're 30 mhm um I would
say budgeting was huge um using every
dollar I liked being able to track you
know each transaction we have um and
every dollar is addicting it is I always
look forward to going to work and you
know moving it over real quick um
particularly for NS but yeah it's
addicting yeah yes um communication was
a big one between us communic about
everything we spend pretty much and like
is this okay we on you know is this in
the budget can we go for this this time
yeah okay let's go for it yeah um when
it got really tough it just we had to
remind ourselves why we doing it this is
the goal you know we're almost there
keep going Teamwork Makes the DreamWork
you know we got to be on the same team
yeah and we want to bring this baby home
to a dead free house so we're not going
out to eat tonight yeah right yeah way
to go y'all and you got the rest of your
lives do anything you want to do now I
know it's surreal yeah and you're
already have a half million dollar net
worth you're going to be baby steps
millionaires in 20 minutes now I mean
it's going to happen so fast it's
ridiculous the next one's going to come
home to a Millionaire's house you know
that's that's where you're going to be
that's that's how fast it'll roll
because you got no payments no payments
you get wealthy I mean and your
generosity Factor this time of year
particularly you start seeing it you
know around Christmas so you can go just
bananas with stuff you don't have to but
you've got the margin to you know and
you know find somebody that's in need
you can do all kinds of stuff to help
people I mean it's it's a cool place to
be I'm exced very cool place to be yeah
I love it I love it listen here's what I
want people to hear okay that the the
sigh of relief even as you're recounting
it you said this is very surreal and you
guys have got total freedom to do
whatever you want to do now and I think
that people need to understand the
exchange for all the sacrifice is true
Freedom when we talk about peace it's
freedom to make the choices you want to
make to live the life you want to live
that's what's on the other side of this
and that's what I see with you guys it's
really exciting yeah it's a great
feeling it really
is way to go we're proud of you Heroes
you took control of your life you got
keep control of it for the rest of your
life you're an unusual married couple uh
you you know you actually get along you
actually communicate uh I mean we
watched it happen I asked a couple
questions both of you knew the answers
to the questions at the start of this
time together I mean you you both are on
the same pack this is what we're doing
this is who we are this is where we're
going and there's nobody dragging their
feet nobody having a hissy fit like a
four-year-old we're both going to go win
like two freaking adults you know I'm so
proud of y'all well done thank you well
done this kid's got a great set of
parents are you going to are you what's
your baby's name it's cormic cormick
okay so here comes cormic into the shot
cuz if we're going to do a debt-free
scream we got to have the reason for
doing it in here that's good how cute
that's so fun all right Lance and Morgan
and cormick who has no idea from
Evansville Indiana
$168,000 paid off that's their house and
everything before their 30th birthday
did it in 35 months making 140 to
195 count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're de free
yeah oh
yeah didn't even pH for me he's Still
rocking no he just thr his brow like
what's yelling about what's Mom yelling
about pretty cool very fun
congratulations you two absolutely
beautifully done hey we've got the live
and give box for you it includes the
baby steps millionaires book Because as
I mentioned earlier you're about 20
minutes from being there you'll be
surprised how fast that'll happen now
and uh of course The Total Money Maker
over book you can give that to someone
who's uh doesn't believe your story but
if you follow the plan the plan works
people it's not rocket surgery you can
do it it's really simple it's just hard
that's the deal and of course a
Financial Peace University membership is
in the living give box as well so thanks
for coming down from Evansville Indiana
we're proud of you Heroes way to go
Lance and Morgan and cormick you got it
down buddy this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much takes too
long but something as simple as custom
window coverings from blinds.com can
completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
apply
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the Ramsey show
thank you for for joining us Jack is in
Portland Oregon hi Jack welcome to the
Ramsey Show hey Dave hey Ken thanks for
having me sure what's
up hey so my question is uh my wife and
I are looking to purchase our first
house uh in the near future here and I'm
kind of curious uh if you think we
should keep saving and pay cash being
that we are close to affording it or
should we get a small mortgage Ag and
maybe the pros and cons to each of those
situations what's your household
income household income is around
150,000 okay and uh what have you got
saved
now we have uh around the end of the
year we will be at uh around 300,000
okay and what's the price of the
house uh we're looking in the range from
400 to
450 okay so you're talking about like
three more years or so
right if you pay
cash yeah I mean hopefully not we've I
mean we've saved up what we have really
quickly well how out of $150,000
household income what are you saving a
year uh roughly 70 okay A little over
maybe okay so it's two to three years
then yeah okay all right or you take out
a small 150 and you pay it off in 2 to
three years right right y okay well
there's actually one of the few things
on this show there's two answers to um
answer number one is I don't borrow
money and I'm always a little bit
uncomfortable telling somebody to do
something I won't do but anytime you
take out a mortgage that's something I
won't do and so if this was sharing in
me we don't have an option we have to
wait and pay cash because we don't
borrow money for anything ever under any
circumstances I will never be a diamond
in Deb again ever for any reason there's
nothing I'm scared enough of or want
badly enough to get in debt for it ever
again nothing period so I'm not
borrowing money so we would wait and pay
cash that doesn't mean you're wrong and
we it because taking out a mortgage as
you know from listening to the show Jack
is something we don't yell at people for
on this show now if you go take out a
stupid but car loan I'll yell at you for
being a fool okay but not but just for
your own good not cuz I like to yell at
you but I'm just going to call you a
fool so because it's going to keep you
from getting rich that's the bottom line
and so but that's you know in your case
if you take out a mortgage it's a
15-year fixed where the payment's less
than a fourth of your take-home pay
that's the maximum mortgage we tell
people to do with the whole idea of turn
around getting it paid off as fast as
you can you know all that Jack and so
that's one end of the spectrum the other
end of the spectrum is I tell people I
don't borrow money at all so you could
do the I don't borrow money at all and
wait two years and pay cash or you could
take out a small Mortgage and pay it off
in two or three years
and you're well within the range of what
we say to do on the show so either
answer is okay with what we teach on the
show you see what I'm saying yes yep
okay what is the living conditions where
you are
now uh they're pretty good actually I
mean we're happy renting where we're at
our rent is relatively low compared to
if we were to move to another area if I
ask your wife does she give me the same
answer yes you hesitated
yeah I I have a feeling I'm talking to
the nerd tightwad and she's not exactly
well you you're correct okay all right
and my I mean she would say buy the
house and pay off the mortgage quickly
you would say I want to save and wait
yes we're just so close to being there
that we're getting you know trigger
happy I'd say yeah yeah well she is and
and yeah you are not and you're trying
to go Dave please tell me I can't do
this but yeah um yeah I I I'm not going
to tell you that because it'd be
inconsistent with what I've told people
for 30 years so uh I'm okay if you go
ahead and buy um prices are not going to
come down in uh Portland Oregon uh I
don't think uh and I don't you know
unless Portland and of itself has issues
but um which it does but depending on
where you are in Portland actually as to
whether or not you're going to see price
problems but that's a political climate
thing that's not a
um
uh it's it's not it's a Law and Order
thing it's not a uh um uh a an economic
thing for you so as long as you're you
know outside the realm of where issues
are and you're in a stable area that
you're talking about buying prices are
not going to go down in that area of
Portland Oregon you're going to be fine
and I I would not wait for prices to
come down uh the interest rates are
irrelevant because you're going to pay
it off so fast you're not even know you
had an interest rate
right and uh now what I would want to do
if we go with her side of the deal where
we're getting where we're getting house
fever and start looking in the spring
and buy something I would want a firm
commitment that the two of you sit down
pinky swear spit Shake sign a little
agreement together or whatever to where
you both are saying when we buy the
house we're going to lean in and pay it
off in this many months
because I it wouldn't be fair to you
your side of the feelings and argument
for you to buy and then she goes oh
we're gonna pay it off in four years
instead because I want to furnish
it right that's not fair to you because
you're saying we can pay it off in two
or three and she needs to commit to that
if you guys are going to wa if you're
not going to wait you follow me that's
just a relationship thing though that's
not a math thing y because what'll
happen is you go in there it's easy to
just say oh we got to go back buy the
$2,500 playet for the
backyard yeah and um didn't have to have
that before but now we got to have it
you know and there's all this stuff that
you need to have after you buy a new
house that you don't really need to have
like people spending 18,000 bucks to
decorate the nursery for a child that
takes up about four square inches of
place you know it's just like ridiculous
people go bananas we had to do that for
the baby the baby doesn't even know it
you did it for yourself that's a lie so
you know that it's the same kind of
arguments people get into there so I I
don't care which way you go what Ken
what would you and Stacy do I would buy
it now and the reason is I'm just
looking at the real estate market and
even though rates have gone up uh we see
that the inventory is really low and so
housing values haven't dropped now
you've seen housing uh purchases drop
but prices haven't and to your point I
just don't see a situation where uh
they're going to get a better deal on a
house so I'd go ahead and buy now with
his intensity and pay it off quickly
yeah but but agree to oh agree 100%
36-month plan or whatever the plan is
okay let do the math and go okay we're
going to take $150,000 mortgage and
we're going to pay it off at 70 and so
that's 24 months right I agree cuz
they're saving 70,000 a year on $150,000
income that's extreme saving I got a lot
of Hope and Faith that he's going to pay
that house off and she as well if it
doesn't if the whole idea doesn't get
sidetracked and that's what he's a
little bit afraid of I think so but I
think she you're you're you've had more
experience than this yes she wants the
house you nailed that but she's also
gone along with this she hasn't fought
him she's on board to save 70 grand a
year they're on board yeah they're
they're hardcore so I feel really good
about that's what I would do Dave only
because I'm going three years from now
or two years from now what are the
housing that housing is that going to go
up to 500 that 400 to 450 is that going
to go for 450 to so from that standpoint
I probably buy now if I find something I
like I do think that even if house
prices are stagnant for the next 24
months right
as soon as the market is enlivened again
we're going to see them jump up I think
you're right because demand any any
gains you get by an interest rate
reduction in your payment you're going
to lose in a price increase yeah I agree
because people are sidelined and they're
all going to come back to the they're
all going to come back to the game like
they did after you know after the fouchy
pandemic right they're going to come
back to the game after that yeah well
I've asked you about this before I'd
love you to share with our audience you
know U let's say we got another year of
sevens all of a sudden if if we see
something in the high fives there's a
psychology to that and people go well
that's a lot better than the seven and
so now they move it's exactly the
opposite psychology of what we had we
went from three to four and you would
have thought we shot people that's right
it's true it's true three to four right
you know I'm selling real estate in
1982 and the interest rates went down
from 16 to
14 and the flood Gates opened I sold 78
houses that year I was 22 years old I
just had a horrible but slightly
entertaining thought could you imagine
if interest rates on on mortgages were
14 to 16% right now Tik Tock would
melt you know oh there's there's
something we that generation would melt
there's something we could hope
for this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one bestselling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host thanks
for joining us the phone number is
5225 Marcus is in Oklahoma City hey
Marcus welcome to the Ramsey Show hey
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up uh I'll just be quick and to
the point 2020 2021 I was working a
mortgage company um they closed their
doors in 2022 I was making quite a bit
uh now I'm a teacher didn't file my
taxes for 2020 and 2021 uh probably 80%
of that was um obviously commission so I
did dumb uh I know I need to file those
now obviously and I'm GNA owe quite a
bit I was just going to see if I can
maybe get some um advice on how to go
about doing that in the the least
harmful
way
ouch okay here here's the thing not
paying tax taxes is not a criminal act
not filing taxes is a criminal
act that's what's weird we do not have a
debtor's prison they don't put people in
jail for not paying their taxes but they
do put people in jail about 2 200 a year
for failure to file okay so that's where
that's the danger that you're in I'm
more concerned about that then I am the
payment plan I don't think you're in
trouble and because 90 9% of the time
that you're not some Pol not some public
figure that you come and self F you know
you catch up your filings they're just
all late um you don't get into any
criminal issues but I want you to get it
done now I don't want them to come find
you okay I want you to go to them like
immediately no later than the middle of
January these documents need to be filed
okay yes sir you know that's the Panic
then the second issue is how do we pay
it well number one we've got to assess
the damage and figure out from the
actual filings what you actually
owe and then um you know your worst case
scenario is you're selling some stuff
and putting uh the KGB I mean the IRS on
a payment
plan okay so uh because I mean if you
were doing mortgage origination in 2020
you made some Bank yes sir yeah like
what'd you make that year probably 2 250
and you paid zero tax
yes
sir did you save
any yeah yeah got got about uh probably
100,000 save oh good okay because you're
probably GNA have $100,000 tax bill oh
yeah okay if you got two years of that
you will yeah easy yeah so you're going
to give them what you got to limit it
and then you're going to work out the
payments what you've got to have is a
real tax Pro in your corner right now
and if you'll go to Ramsey solutions.com
and click on the tax ELP for your area
there in Oklahoma City I know them
they're good people they can sit down
with you and help you first get the
filings done and then secondly negotiate
the payment plan and how much of this
you got to throw at them to keep them
off your bank account because we don't
want them putting leans on everything
after you file but also don't want them
putting bracelets on you that connect
because you didn't
file yes sir so we need to get filed and
uh and then we need to develop the the
how tough the path is that we've got to
walk through do you own a home yes sir
what's it
worth uh about 500 what do you owe about
200 okay well and and what is your
household income
nowadays um probably about 70 I have
three jobs right now so I'm a teacher
I'd do some data entry at night and i'
wait some tables on the weekends you
have any money other than the
uh no you have any money in retirement
you have money in retirement I do okay
all right I do not tell people to cash
out retirement for um for to pay off
debt I might to pay off the IRS to keep
from selling your
home you follow me so that's what you've
got to get into you've got to ascertain
cuz let's just say this okay let's say
it's 150 and you throw A1 down and you
say okay we're going to pay uh 20 or
we're going to pay $2,000 a month for
three years and we'll be out of debt
that's okay but if it's a if it's 200
and you put a 100 down and you're going
to be in debt for a decade you don't
want that you need to you need to clean
out something else the house or the
retirement accounts and clean up the
mess so the not filing and it's not the
not filing the not paying and the not
filing I hope it's not a ton more than
the 100 when you get there it's going to
be something more than that but you you
need to get you need
to understand the size of the problem
the uh the not knowing is a bigger
stress inducer than knowing the details
so you've got the cancer diagnosis you
just don't know what the treatment is
yet and you don't know whether it's
terminal you you know so that first
thing they do is they scare you to death
and you go around for about two months
with or two weeks with no information
and then they start going okay well
here's the treatment plan Oh you mean
I'm not going to die well that would
would have been handy information about
a week ago you know and that's kind of
what you're dealing with here is that
same set of
emotions so
um you know the uh uh yeah get with a
tax Pro today when you hang up open up
Ramsey solutions.com click on taxpro ELP
at uh Oklahoma City and go sit down with
them this week I don't give a crap if
it's Christmas uh you know you need to
give yourself a gift to getting this
monkey off your back oh man that's scary
yeah and I hope he has he saves some
money I hope he also has some write-offs
and records of that kind of stuff um so
that he can you know the better the
better your records the more you can
limit this yes that's exactly right
write offs and Records tax Pro here is
huge though do not try to figure this
out on your own no and don't go ask the
IRS what to do oh yeah good Lord yeah
it's like asking a dog if it's hungry
you know no we don't do that so you know
where did you get your tax information
from the IRS oh my God you're a fool you
know no no no no no no no we don't we
don't ask them we don't ask the fox
about the hen house hello yeah so yeah
oh oh yeah they're tasty and by the way
don't ask them for Grace either because
they don't have any U this is get your
tax Pro to help you me Grace quit I used
to talk to Grace no I used to talk to
her weekly she called me all the time
it's like from Christmas Vacation she
died 10 years
ago yeah yeah they they're just not
going to be kind and a tax Pro here is
going to be your advocate and they know
everything that they they can do they're
they're worth it so don't try to
navigate this on your own yeah and and
there's and here's the last part of this
okay the these commercials that are on
cable TV do you have $10,000 or more in
tax debt we can get it forgiven we have
X IRS agents working for us just give us
$5,000 and we will promptly do nothing
for the next 24 months that's what that
is that's a complete freaking scam
there's a thing called the OIC and and
offer in compromise that you can get
your federal income taxes forgiven about
1% of them are approved you have to
prove total popers ship meaning you
don't have a house you don't have a job
you don't have any potential income and
you don't have any assets of any kind
and then they will forgive your debt
after fooling with them for about 2 and
a half years don't answer those stupid
butt cable tv ads go get a tax Pro and
actually work a plan to get the mess
cleaned up this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial pece and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
a debt settlement company and they're
not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Sarah's with us in Honolulu HI
Sarah welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you for taking my call
sure what's up my question is um what I
should do with an inher inheritance that
I'll be
receiving okay how much of an
inheritance did you
get
180,000 wow who left you
that oh my mom oh I'm sorry when did she
pass
hun um earlier this year oh my I'm sorry
how old are
you I'm 52
52 yes okay cool what do you make a
year my husband and I's um household
income is 250,000 net that's good
okay so um how long have you been
listening to
us a while off and on okay so you've
heard us talk about the baby steps I
assume yes we don't have any uh debt
except for our mortgage that we ow
10,000
okay um do you have an emergency
fund yes it's 55,000 all right good do
you have um anything sa for your kids
college or are they grown and
gone um they're grown they're kind of
doing it now we and we do have in our
checken account um we have 100,000 right
now okay all right for
what um I don't know we're just
just you don't know what to do we're
just overthinking everything and um so
you have 100,000 in addition to this
180 yes okay so that's 280 and you owe
400 and you make
250 yes okay all right well as you
probably have heard if you've listened
for just a few minutes on the show we
know that from the data we have and the
30 years of experience doing this that
as we talk with millionaires they have
two two primary areas that cause them to
become their F to get their first $1 to5
million of net worth and the two primary
areas are a paid for house and their
builtup retirement
plan you know investing steadily into
your 401K Roth IRAs and those sorts of
things and so we teach people to become
debt-free other than their home in baby
steps two and then three is have an
emergency fund you've done those baby
step four is invest 15% of your income
into retirement you should already be
doing that or you should start doing
that five as kids college does not apply
here yours are grown and gone and sixes
pay off the house early so if you were
to work the baby steps you would apply
any free money that you have not
counting an emergency fund not counting
putting 15% of your income towards
retirement any other free money that you
have like for instance $180,000
inheritance or any free money that you
have like for instance an extra hundred
grand laying around sloppily in the
checking account I would throw all of
those towards paying off your home as
soon as possible if you did that you
would only owe about $100,000 on your
house and you could pay it off in a
couple of
years okay and if you had a paid for
house then that'd be a whole cool thing
because that house in Honolulu is Pretty
stinking
expensive yes what's it
worth I believe about 1.1 yeah yeah okay
so paid for house alone makes you A
Millionaire right yes it does so any
objection to paying off your
house um the only um thing that we've
been thinking about is that um we may
have we may may not have to move in a
year or two to the West Coast and we
haven't decide been able to decide where
we want to retire when my husband
retires in seven years so we're just
kind of like that doesn't matter you can
sell the house when you
move okay you're not giving the money
away you're you're putting you're paying
off a house when you sell the house they
give you a
check okay and then another option was
as smart Pro said that um we
could invest the money until it builds
up to the amount that we need to pay off
the mortgage no they didn't if they did
they're not going to be a smart Vestor
Pro anymore because that's contrary to
what we teach and they know that
okay I'll fire them for doing
that they can't I will not endorse
someone that says to do that and a smart
Vestor Pro is who I endorse so you hang
on we need to find out who it was that
said that and I want to follow up on
this story and make sure you got your
story straight before I fire them so cuz
that's not what we teach people to do
and we don't send people to Smart Vestor
Pros who teach them to do something
different than what we
teach we never tell someone to build up
enough in their mutual fund with their
smart proo until they pay off their
house we tell them pay off the stinking
house as fast as you P can throw the
money at it as fast as you can so either
you misunderstood or they're getting
ready to get fired one of the two so uh
we'll find out about that we'll have uh
Austin pick up and find out what the
real what really is going on here but um
no you need to pay off your house son
throw the money at the house that's what
I would do you called and ask me now
you're a grownup you get to do whatever
you want to do but um I don't think your
mom who left you this money is going to
be mad when your house is paid off I
think it's a great legacy a great tip of
the hat to your mom a great way of
honoring her uh to have your home paid
off the difference in stability in your
life the difference in future wealth
building making $250,000 living in a
million dollar paid for house how fast
you will be able to add to your wealth
is is mindboggling it's mindboggling so
hang on Austin will pick up we'll get to
the bottom of that open phones at
5225 that's sometime type of thing
sometimes comes up so we've got about
5,000 6,000 people that we endorse
through our uh smart Vestor Pro program
or whether it is through the ELP program
with real estate taxes and so on uh we
require all those people to first and
foremost have the heart of a teacher we
require them second to give advice that
is consistent with the advice that you
hear
here so that I'm not telling you to do
one thing and then someone I send you to
is telling you to do something else that
would be
hypocritical and then you're just
confused because of the inconsistent
lack of Integrity that that represents
so that is that is something we require
so when we tell you to go to a Smart VOR
Pro you're going to get the heart of a
teacher and advice that is consistent
with what you hear here and that advice
is not consistent yeah and as a matter
of fact it's almost perpendicular well
and I wanted you to explain why because
I think it that makes a lot of sense to
people okay put it in the mutual fund
let it gain some why do we teach the
opposite to say no let's knock the house
out get on that not save it up in an
investment fund and then pay it off why
because in my experience of doing this
for 30 years when you build up 400,000
or 200,000 in a mutual fund you end up
doing something stupid butt with it
instead of paying off the house yeah
yeah so it ends up becoming a
distraction it ends up being a problem
rather than a blessing right and um
about half the time about half the time
people actually follow through on it but
but it's a bunch of theoretical hogwash
oh I'm going to make money at 12% the
mutual fund and I'm going to offset the
7% mortgage or 5% mortgage or whatever
I've got no you're not right you're
taking risk here that you're not even
ascertaining you're not even measuring
risk properly yeah so that's just that's
you know I the number of millionaires
that we interviewed out of 10,000
millionaires that said Dave the way we
got rich was we saved up money in mutual
fund and paid off our house almost none
right almost none right that paid off
their house and they dumped money in
their 401ks in mutual funds that's how
they did it it's almost none might be
five or something out of a 10,000 of
them so you know these people all these
people have freaking theories but
they're people with no money they got
all these theories or they've got a
conflict where they're trying to get a
commission that's the issue and so
whether it's it shouldn't be from one of
our better not be from one of the folks
that that me off yeah but put my name on
that there's an agenda Amy trusted hello
yeah good God you know so I'm but most
of the time when we check into this when
it comes up on the air someone
misunderstood or the story was wrong or
whatever so hopefully that's the case
there and it cuz it almost never happens
cuz we're so freaking hard core on the
due diligence with these folks that we
put in these systems cuz Ramsey trusted
does mean something means I trust them
hello and everybody that works here does
hello this is the ramsy show
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage philli
and Rebecca are with us hey guys where
are you hey how are you where you guys
live we're actually from Phoenix City
Alabama which is outside of Auburn
Auburn Alabama and you're wearing an
Aggie shirt I'm so confused uh so we
actually moved to Alabama because I
joined the military so we're actually
from Texas oh okay now I understand all
right well thank you for your service
thank you wh which branch are you in I'm
in the Army I'm a comp competitive
shooter and uh she is a nurse cool okay
so uh competitive shooter now I'm going
to sidebar just a second what the flip
what do you do uh so uh spoiler alert uh
I actually went to the Tokyo Olympics uh
I compete oh with the air rifles then uh
I'm actually shotgun shooter but you're
close okay yeah so I'm a competitive
shooter uh and what they do is they then
take my name and likeness and try to get
people to join as well and show what the
Army uh can provide for you as a career
so with a shotgun correct so you're
talking about Clays and that's me okay
wow okay so you essentially are a
spokesperson for the Army by showcasing
your skill that's exactly right
interesting all right thanks for the
sidebar all right how much that have you
paid off we paid off um
$275,000 in five years in 60 months yeah
and your range of income during that
time uh it was from uh let's see I got
it written down here 115 to 165 okay
very cool and you're in the military we
got that established you said you're a
nurse I'm a nursing director nursing
director okay two great careers very
cool very cool so what kind of debt was
the
275 uh we had a couple of cars and our
mortgage paid off your house paid off
the house couple of weirdos absolutely I
love you wow what's this house worth uh
well it was originally 220 but now it's
about 325 excellent wow how old are you
two 28 27 wow and you have a paid for
house that's worth2
or 300,000 bucks wow wow wow wow wow
well tell us the story how'd you get
turned on to Ramsay and how' you do all
this stuff so I actually uh grew up
listening to you through my parents uh
Financial Peace baby yes I was yep so uh
I listened to you it was right after
some lady that would come on and talk
about uh computers and uh I would tune
in to your channel after hers and uh we
would listen to you on the way home from
Christmas and Thanksgiving and while on
the road so it just kind of got
interested and actually we whenever we
bought our house in 2018 uh about three
days later a hurricane came over and uh
I had never been in debt a quarter
million in my life before and then 3
days later for a hurricane to come over
it kind of sends a little bit of a shock
through you right so then I was like you
know I don't want to be in dead anymore
we should probably listen to what this
Dave guy has to say wow so Kim Commando
I bet yes that was her yeah Kim's a
friend of mine that's awesome yeah she's
been doing talk radio almost long as I
have yeah way to go you guys
congratulations so you did it 275,000
how long you two been married 5 years
okay so the whole time you've been
married we're getting this debt paid off
yep so we actually bought the house just
a few months after we got married okay
all right very fun so uh Rebecca at what
point did you realize you had married a
freak this guy's crazy he listens to
these people on the radio and wants to
get out of Deb I know right well
actually we grew up together so I've
known him my whole life I know I knew
what I was getting you knew what you
were getting too okay childhood
sweethearts yeah there's a picture of us
somewhere where we're both about 8 years
old at a birthday party together so oh
my gosh wow wow there we go very cool
the only thing I can think of is they've
known each other a long time which
probably takes away that weird situation
when he comes to date and his dad her
dad brings out the shotgun then he's
like oh well I better not bring out the
shotgun that could be a really tough
situation there you had some skills I'm
guessing early on I could give him some
lessons I know sorry that's where my
brain goes and oh cool you got a
shotgun yeah yeah he's probably pretty
proud of you as well I'm guessing
absolutely okay here's what I want to
know so you guys start right out of the
gate you know newly Newly Weds and we're
going to go after this big goal was
there a time where you wavered at all or
were you and if you did how did you stay
focused or were you just kind of locked
in the whole time curious great question
so I actually uh like any advice that I
get I don't just like jump all the way
in I kind of like test it a little bit
so it took me a little while to be
honest did not get rid of the credit
cards right away it took me a minute and
then over time it just seemed like
everything that that y'all teach came
true so then as it slowly be became like
a thing that comes true every time I was
like okay maybe I should trust a little
bit more then trust a little bit more so
it just kind of like went from dipping
my toe in the water to Jumping you know
head first that's fair yeah I mean
that's wisdom a good dose of cism will
keep you out of a mess that's right yeah
one other follow-up question and it's
shotgun related I can't help myself
instead of cutting up the cards did you
throw yours in the air and shoot them
I'm just curious uh actually I just went
with the shredder but it would been more
fun to go ahead and shoot him a little
disappointed you didn't do that I'll we
had some people do some pretty creative
plastic surgeries with Firearms um some
some um yeah one guy with a 223 on Full
Auto yeah it was he just shredded them
it was great yeah so a lot of fun good
job you guys I'm proud of you I bet your
parents are hollering and yelling I bet
they're screaming loud oh they'd be
watching I love it I love it well they
should be they should be way to go you
two you got an incredible start you're
going to be multi-millionaires now
somebody else is 28 or 27 or 25 is
listening they're going gosh when I'm 28
I'd like to have paid for a house what
do you tell them the key to getting out
of debt is you just got to be boring I
mean that's the best advice you've ever
given is that everything that you should
do is it should be so boring that you
get tired of it like whenever you're out
and you're you're spending your money
you're trying to make things more
exciting than what they actually have to
be and the secret is that there is no
secret and until you learn that then uh
you know you're not doing it the right
way Rebecca what do you think my advice
would be it's a deliberative act you
have to choose this lifestyle and just
continue moving forward with it um we're
very competitive people by nature and
you know just watching the debt tick
down is what kept us going you gamified
it yep yeah yeah there it's addicting to
run through it and knock it out it is
yeah yeah that's very cool waiting for
the next paycheck to come in so we can
throw more money on it it's kind of dumb
I mean you know it's kind of like I so I
can Mark through these zeros you know
it's like wow but it's not dumb because
when you get there the other side of it
how's it feel now oh amazing yeah there
was this moment you know whenever we we
reached Christmas last year where we had
$70,000 left
and we were like huh wonder if wonder if
we can do 70,000 by next Christmas and
we looked up and it wasn't even
Halloween yet and we had our 70,000
already paid for
so that's awesome when you put it in
front of you that's how it works hey we
got the live and give box for you the
baby steps millionaires book you're
going to be one quick and early wow 28
years old here you are already
absolutely you guys are amazing I'm so
proud of you Heroes well done and thanks
again for your service uh also the
babyss millionaires books in there The
Total Money Makeover books in there
you'll give that to one of your friends
who might have been thinking you were
crazy uh even the uh Financial Peace
University membership so uh all of
that's there the live and give box and
thank you for coming all the way up from
Auburn Alabama and uh thanks again for
your service and Merry Christmas to you
way to go Phillip and Rebecca 275,000
paid off that's house and everything
they did it in the first 5 years of
their marriage hous is worth three
something now they're well on their way
to being baby step millionaires 115,000
income up to 165 debt free house and
everything count it down let's hear a
debt free Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb
[Applause]
free I love it that is so fun that is so
fun that's great feel like we should be
celebrating old west style right now
just firing shotguns in the air you know
C CU they they fired shotguns a lot in
the Old West what are you talking about
well sort of the bar scene it was more
of the revolvers revolvers okay I
understand I took a little bit of yeah
you reached well I went to the west and
I thought instead of the revolver let's
go with the shotgun I was making it all
come together I mean you got to give me
a little creative license here but
that's a great story though another
young couple here who's literally
changed the trajectory of their life
that's two in a row both of them under
30 with paid for houses that's crazy I
mean you know how many years I did this
show before somebody under 30 came on
paid off their house paid off their
house it happened twice just today
already yeah oh my gosh you won't see
that on Tik
Tok you do if you watch this show there
it is cuz we're taking up some space in
that crazy environment this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman ramsy personality is my
co-host you can hear him daily on the
Ken Coleman show and podcast broadcast
on radio on SiriusXM on podcast on
YouTube and he's always talking about
your career and your job and how to make
more money and how to do something fun
with your life where you actually end up
with money
and that's a cool idea uh lots of cool
projects and things around that
including his number one bestselling
book paycheck to purpose he's my co-host
today uh Aaron is in Orlando hi Aaron
how are you I'm doing well how are you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world well I have a couple questions for
you um I'm or right now with the current
economy uh to what either start my own
business or to enter a better paying
trade than what I am currently in uh for
the long call what trade are you
in uh currently I do uh lift station
work um sewage pump stations
um and either for private companies and
then uh I maintain them what do you
make I currently make $24 an hour at 22
okay you're 22 years old oh wow okay and
what trade are you thinking about
pivoting to or moving to are there
several or is there one that's got your
attention the one trade that has my real
attention and has been one I've wanted
to for a while is I would like to do
Line work if I don't start my own
business yeah um big money big money big
money in fact I was I was talking to a
guy a couple weeks ago who runs a line
company training business a line train
these folks and and it's just they're
looking for people there's great
opportunity so what's keeping you from
moving into that he might open his own
business yeah but I want to know the
answer to this first question because I
think I think that helps us with the
second one are you are you truly
considering it you've been thinking
about a long time why haven't you
moved the biggest thing with is economic
climate I live in Florida um and that's
one thing that has kept me from throwing
away a job and going full jumping full
into to try to start my own business and
because right now the price of
everything in Florida is so high
understand not a lot of people have the
money to go ahead why would you be
throwing away a job if you're taking
another job in line that's what I want
to know why you haven't moved towards
that trade the line okay um currently um
one of the biggest things is I would
have to travel and I'm not trying to
jump into a vehicle payment to get a
better vehicle where I can travel
with okay um but you're assuming but
you're assuming that you have to go into
debt to be able to get a decent vehicle
to be able to get to the job you have
any
money I have about uh 2500 in emergency
um after some medical expenses I okay so
when they hire you to do a line job do
they pay a signing bonus of any kind
right now uh no sir um there's a local
union out of oal Florida that I'd be
looking to join um and that's a three
and a half year process to get a
journeyman's card and that would put me
in the range of 44 an hour okay yeah all
right so it's not instantaneous this
takes a while all right now the business
idea takes 20 minutes to start but you
just don't know whether to do it right
now what is
it it's fencing I have some experience
doing it from I used to work at
municipality um and I have some
experience doing that um
building yes or building and installing
uh clearing the land to go ahead and
install the
F commercial fencing or
residential uh residential is what I
have experienced with um like cattle
fence and then residential privacy what
kind of equipment do you need for
that if I need an equip equipment
the ideal and what you would really need
to turn over a profit margin would be a
small Good Steer with an augur is the
best piece of equipment you can use if
you're not trying to break your back and
it saves about 75% okay so what's a good
one going to
cost 10,000 yeah yeah so now you know
what you're dealing with I I don't want
to make your decision for you or hang
something on you but I would say that I
think that you should try saving up the
money for the augur and let's see if we
can get a couple contracts here and
there but this isn't an all-in situation
I don't think you have to I don't think
you have to quit your job to start
working on fencing as a side gig yeah I
agree I think you can pick up some side
gigs with it break your back for a
little while you're 22 and and and dig
some holes man and and build a fence or
two get the profit from that by the skid
steer used yeah and then you can
increase your profits and increase your
speed
but um listen there's there's never an
economy that allows you to start a
business ever that's easy it's always
hard the worst ball she'll ever have is
working for
yourself that guy is a butthole he will
work you to
death follow me yes sir but you're not
eron you're not we're we're just
metaphorically speaking
yes I I currently do do fencing as a
side gig and that's part of what's
keeping me from one of these jump pull
in as well is I currently do do it as a
side gig um picking up contract are you
making any money
um I yes sir um
the yes and no depending on help um down
here it's very hard to find help uh
especially my area um you can't really
find anyone who is anything some want so
here's the deal I don't want in any way
to to you know squelch the dream here
but that's this is some really good data
you're getting as to whether or not is
this something I really want to do and I
think you've got some real options here
you know what the path to moving into
the trade of being a linesman looks like
and maybe you can launch a business once
you get into that industry and really
get some great experience and they pay
you well to learn the trade I think
you're at an inflection point where you
have to decide is this if I had the
10,000 if I had all the clients would I
really want to do the fence business
when I'm 30 years old what am I going to
be glad I did
yeah okay that's the way you ask it when
I'm 32 years old 10 years from today a
decade from now and where whatever you
do both of these things are hard
physical work both of these things have
risk both of these things have strain
both of these are hard both of of them
have tremendous income
potential either way the economy or it's
hard to get labor are not your problems
what your problem is is you're going to
have to decide what you want to do with
your life for the next
decade and you want to look up at 32
years old and own a residential fence
company with 25 people working for you
running jobs all over the city and
you're run around checking the jobs and
you're checking your profits and you're
estimating and you've dialed it in and
you've become known in the in in the
area as the go-to guy for fencing and is
that who you want to be or do you want
to be a lineman and uh high risk hard
work um but unions dictating you know
when you're working where you're working
all that kind of stuff uh You're Not
Your Own Boss uh but you've got a
tremendous income Y and U and pretty
steady too yeah pretty steady it's not
an old man's game that's true uh you
won't be doing it when you're 60
probably
but I got to say this those kind of
Trades can fund another trade or fund
your entrepreneurial venture and you
being a small business person if you
want to stay in the trades you know I
see guys all the time that are jumping
from trade to trade to trade they made
really good money in one trade that
funded them being able to start their
business so I would look really hard at
that long-term what does that 30-year
play look like for you yeah what what do
we want to do in the next decade where
do I want to end up and that should tell
you where you're going don't let whining
about the economy whining about it's
hard to find good help let me just tell
you I've been running a business for 30
years it's hard to find good
help period yeah most people don't care
most people don't work hard so don't
hire them don't hire most people I got a
building full of Champions but I go
through a lot of turds to get some
Champions too you know a lot of them
over the years so that's just part of
running a business man it's hard nothing
you're signing up for is easy but uh
you're the hero material you can do it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
go
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones this hour as
we talk about your life and your money
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality career
expert number one bestselling author of
the book paycheck to purpose and host of
the Ken Coleman show he's my co-host
today the phone number is open phones at
88255 225 today's question of the day
comes from neighborly your hub for Home
Services here at Ramsay we believe in
making home ownership a blessing not a
burden so we recommend neighborly
Nationwide network of service
professionals to help repair maintain
and improve your home find the help you
need at neighborly
docomo I got a new job recently and I
have a boss from hell I'm pretty sure
I'm going to get fired soon the problem
is I enjoy the work and I get paid well
I tried looking for other jobs similar
to this but there is none in my area I
feel like I'm walking on eggshells at
work like I know it's a matter of time
before I get fired I pause baby step two
to start saving in case I get fired I
now have $2,200 saved up I figure we can
live on one income if we sell our cars
and take our kid out of daycare should I
start one looking for a new job two
downgrade everything except child care
to prepare for the worst case scenario
if I downgrade and get a job I'll have
that extra income to pay off debt which
is a substantial amount so yeah you
should be looking for a job right away
uh and taking maybe one or two extra
jobs while looking if you really feel
like the shoe is about to drop and you
can get fired at any moment you just
want to be stacking cash which means
making some extra cash right now if it
were this bad the way you're describing
it um I would be working extra saving
extra pausing some things sure but let's
move quickly um because you know what
the work is I'm not going to accept the
reality just automatically that I've
tried looking for job similar list but
there's none in my area you were looking
for one when you found that one yeah I
just never want to accept that that's
just that's a bull crap okay you know
there's no houses for rent in this area
of course there's houses for rent in
your area you just don't like them you
know so yeah you need to look for
another position immediately and I you
know I'm going to throw in one other
thing I I do not I cannot tell this from
this
email
but I I Jeff I want you to ask yourself
are you
whining is your boss really the boss
from Hell or you're the lame employee
from
hell you just got the job you walk in
the
door and they ask you to do some work
and you don't like that are you
whining it might not be true yeah but I
would want to ask myself that question
well you actually make a why is it that
you're so freaking useless that even the
boss from hell is going to fire you
quickly well let me throw another
scenario that could be out there too
this could be a boss who may be not the
boss from hell but it's got a lot of
crap going on in their own life personal
life maybe they're stressed out of their
mind and this boss isn't talking to you
with the sweetest kindest of demeanors
and voice and maybe he's a little grumpy
and and maybe you're not going to get
fired at all maybe they got some rough
stuff going on in their life and you
think because of the way they're
treating you you're going to get fired
yeah like are you whining that's what
I'm asking that's right but what's the
cause of them thinking that the boss is
from hell maybe they're just having a
bad day or a couple bad days and you're
not going to everybody that disagrees
with you is not a
narcissist yeah it's interesting you
know everybody that you don't like the
the way they said something does not is
not a toxic work environment M and
people telling you to do your job is not
a toxic work environment that's like you
buckle up buttercup you know so I don't
know if that's what's going on or not
yeah could be sometimes that stuff comes
up it doesn't come up here we don't run
into it much because you don't even make
it through the interview process if
you're going to be that wimpy here cuz
we get crap done and we don't pull any
punches we just I could be the boss from
hell cuz I like believe you ought to
work and stuff cuz you got to outwork me
and I'm 63 years old and been doing this
40 years so keep up kiddo you know
Buckle in so this is what we're doing I
mean if you're not going to do that
you're not going to like me yeah I agree
yeah you
would oh I'm Jeff I don't know that
that's you but if you're ever facing
this I I'm increasingly hearing and Ken
is too in the career space that every
environment that is that feels
momentarily unpleasant like I'm going to
get a callous is a toxic work
environment yes and that's just the the
wussification of America that's right
you're just being a wuss you know suck
it up and and you know dig you know get
the shovel dig the hole man yeah I mean
if that's really what's going I don't
know if that's what's going on so Jeff
ask yourself are are you whining are you
being a wuss is it really that bad are
you exaggerating and melodramatic this I
mean you just took the job how could you
mess up the interview that bad yeah well
let me here's here's another clue in
this I enjoy the work he says and I get
paid well people don't enjoy doing stuff
they suck at so he's either delusional
and I don't think he is or I think this
is an emotional situation he doesn't
like the way he's being talked to and
treated and I get that whether he's
whining or not but the isues don't think
that the boss is going to fire you just
because they're not talking to you with
roses and you know and and treats and
you know that's the issue people quit
too soon in these days because they want
to be coddled that's what I'm saying you
can't get coddled at the work I'm saying
and and it's not it's not you know I do
not expect anyone to stay in a
real toxic work environment but asking
someone to work yeah and correcting them
if they don't do the work properly is
not a toxic work environment that's
called training yeah okay
I you know I think back to my favorite
coach all time Benny pulk high school
basketball if you would have watched
those practices from outside the gym
doors and just watched his demeanor you
would have thought he was verbally
abusing us he wasn't he was Co well in
today's world he was but he was just
coaching us and and I think there's a
difference between verbal abuse bullying
and all the stuff we hear about and then
just good oldfashioned tough-nosed
leadership sometimes it's not all roses
and pom poms well I mean you know you so
Jeff I am not accusing you of that I am
suggesting though that just reading
through the email and the way this is
put together that you know maybe you
need to analyze is how much of this is
you um if it's not you and it's truly
just a guy that's being a twerp and he's
a jerk and he's yelling and screaming or
something I wouldn't ask you to work
there we don't yawn scream at ramsy we
don't cuss at our team we don't do that
we don't abuse we we're not the bosses
from hell but I have been accused of
being that just cuz I told somebody get
up off their butt and get their stuff
done okay and if you don't like that you
don't need to work around here cuz we
get stuff done you know we leave the
cave kill something and drag it home
pretty regular and when you kill
something usually there's blood so get
ready you know I mean there's there's
crap going on here all right so this is
what's going on
and so you got to decide if that's you
know that that's a part of the equation
here like I I've been fired from jobs 2
and you know one time I got fired is
100% my fault it took me a little while
to realize that when I went broke it was
100% my fault you know who got me broke
the idiot in my mirror and one of the
best things I did in my life is
discovered that he was the problem this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the Ramsay cash giveaway
is here you could win one of our $500
weekly prizes are the grand prize of
$5,000 enter every day to increase your
chances of winning at Ramy solutions.com
giveaway no purchase necessary of course
you can also get meaningful gifts for
Christmas during our $12 sale shop our
bestselling books like The Total Money
Makeover baby steps Millionaires and our
own your past and own your past change
your future all Dr John delony Books
Dave Ramsey books and so on for $12 each
the questions for humans conversation
card
as low as $10 right now and the popular
questions for humans Christmas edition
is back there it is and we've got the
New Year's Edition Christmas New Year's
these sold out pretty quick last year
we've got a handful of them I know we've
got at least two left cuz I'm holding
them yeah these are great for U you know
navigating the awkward moments with
family you only see once or twice a year
just keep you from discussing co co and
politics which are kind of the same same
thing yeah so hey check it all out chop
shop the sale at ramsy solutions.com
store Shannon is in Orlando hi Shannon
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi hi what's up thank you for
having me how can we help I am my
husband and I are in
$130,000 of debt um we have about
$120,000
income um I opened a business
and right now it's not going very
well um I'm working a fulltime job aside
from the business my husband is working
um two jobs and um we're just trying to
figure out what we need to do here
should we let go of the failing business
should
we we started reading your financial
piece and we're trying to start the baby
steps right now we have no savings I I
put everything into this business
um the $130,000 in debt is that on the
business no that's that's between us um
the business is debt-free
um because I paid everything cash long
story short sold a house that was given
to me and we moved to a different um
place what kind of business did you
open I opened a medical um uniform store
there wasn't one in where we live and
there's a lot of medical places here um
I'm a nurse and I like to have to drive
35 miles to get some place for uniform
so um I did a survey found out that
other people felt the same and I opened
up a store so why did they not
come I've done everything I came for
marketing um everything I can within my
budget and I've blown my budget and now
I don't know what to do because some
people say it's the season most people
are focused on their children not
themselves either way it doesn't matter
because I'm sinking
H so you have a physical location that
you've rented correct and you have how
much in
inventory I have about $40,000 in
inventory okay so what is
sinking what where are your what cost do
you
have so um monthly for um the business
is $2,800 that's the rent that's the the
utilities and
um that is um well actually it does have
debt I am leased the
um I am lease the embroidery machine the
embroidery machine okay how much is the
monthly payment on the embroidery
machine
$700 okay you make 120,000 not counting
this business right correct okay have
you did how long a lease did you sign on
the property on the on the location
and how long when is that
up that is up in
June so you've only had this open for
six
months
correct and I haven't even made $2,000
from sales yet okay so you have no
traffic no foot traffic at
all a few few people a
week
how many hours are you working at your
day
job I'm I'm a nurse I do um three 12 one
week 412 the other week I work night and
then I um come into the shop from 11: to
6 okay you need to close the shop and
you need to sell this out of your car
you need to start setting appointments
with doctors and nurses to meet them at
the hospital or at their medical and go
take the stuff to them sell it to them
go back home and embroider it and bring
it back the next day you need to you
need to be a clothing specialist out of
your
car you're a food truck
now and talk to your landlord about what
you can pay them to get out of the
lease okay because your problem is your
business
model you're sitting you you you did a
Field of Dreams here build it and they
will come that always fails
no one just looks up Suddenly 6 months
two months 60 days after you open your
doors and goes oh I'm going to rush over
there and buy $2,000 worth of uniforms
it just doesn't
happen so what you would have had to
build here would have taken a long time
for people to know where you are and
then start coming and whatever marketing
you did was an abject
failure so what you've got to do is get
in front of people people's faces go
knock on their door call them talk to
nurses talk to doctors that you know and
that you know that you and 22 people
that know somebody that you
know and spread the word that you will
come to their office fit them embroidery
it and bring it back the next day and do
a cash transaction and you get rid of
$40,000 worth of inventory and then you
decide if you want to keep doing it or
not but at least you can get your
inventory sold that way and stop the
bleeding by doing a negotiation with the
landlord and get out of the
lease sitting there and waiting on this
to bleed out is not a good
idea that's what you already know that's
what you said I'm just saying it more
graphically correct okay you're all
you've already realized what I'm doing
is not working something has to change
and if I just sit here it's just going
to bleed me to death
right
you're okay the biggest thing you are
right now is
scared yes yeah and a little bit ashamed
so shanea just practically where are
people buying their uniforms all these
people in all these medical facilities
in your area where are they buying them
online no they're going to a town about
40 miles away 35 miles away why are they
driving past
you uh because that's where they've been
going for the past few years when there
wasn't a place year to go yeah but now
there's a place to go why are they
driving past
you they don't even know you're there is
why yeah I don't know you're there
Shannon what Dave gave you it sounds
like a lot of Hustle but it's actually
really practical you got to start
talking to nurses how many nurses do you
know and you just start telling them
I've been I've I've gone to every
nursing home I've gone to every hospital
I've gone to every place that use
medical scrubs personally myself for 3
days I walked every place in my County
and gave out flyers spoke to people did
you show them the uniforms did you have
the fabric in your hands actual
uniforms no no no what I did was tell
them the brands that I carry because
we're pretty familiar with these Brands
um the nurses and medical and all of
that created zero
sales so far yeah when did you do
that I did that a week before I
opened something's wrong okay yeah
there's something missing in the story
that you're not seeing because you're
not able to tell us what it is there's a
gaping hole in this story okay so here's
the thing when we open a business we
pour our heart and soul into it it's
very emotional and the idea of failure
starts looming over us it can shut down
our
thinking and I I I got a real sense
you're
paralyzed you you there's a sense of
deer in the headlights here okay and
that's a normal reaction it doesn't mean
you're weak it doesn't mean you're bad
you actually are pretty cool you're
pretty smart but you missed something in
this so somehow I'm going to get out of
this lease I'm putting this uniforms in
my basement I'm either going to burn
them in the backyard or I'm going to go
find a way to sell them online or out of
the back of my car or one of the two and
at least try to get my money back and if
I can discover a business model while
doing that maybe we've got something to
continue but you're not bankrupt you're
just scared and a little bit of shamed
that you made a mistake if I quit every
time I'm made a mistake around here we'd
have been closed up a long time
[Music]
ago
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Ken yes did you hear that
mint the budgeting app
it's closing they shuttered it Dave shut
it down the end of the year it's gone
gone poof smoke done nada nothing yes if
you got a budget on it mint what I'm
telling you is the end of the year
you're
screwed you're
done they're trying to move you over to
Credit
Karma but it doesn't have budgeting
function so it's kind of stupid right
but uh okay go ahead and do that if you
want but um so here's the deal what's
happened is hundreds of thousands of
people as a result have automatically
moved their budgeting stuff over to our
every dollar app which is one of the
best world's best budgeting apps and
already was and U we're not going to try
to sell you a bunch of credit cards
which is what mint was doing and they
quit their effectiveness on converting
you into credit went away so they quit
doing it um so every dollar is there
it's a worldclass budging app it helps
you manage your money the Ramsay way it
works wherever you are iOS Android
online it's
free and immediately you see where
you're stand with your money you get
organized you
personalize it's a lot more usable and
user friendly than it was anyway but you
don't even have men as an option now so
there you go I I can't say I'm sad I'm
not sad I'm happy to have a bunch of new
customers and I'm happy for you
customers cuz you're going to have so
much better EXP experience and we're not
going anywhere we're not trying to sell
a bunch of stuff we're just trying to
get you in every dollar I mean we're not
trying to get you on a credit card debt
we're not trying to get you in a rocket
mortgage or whatever else we're not
trying to do any of that so we'll
proactively coach you on how to become
wealthy and reach your goals download
the free app on iOS or Android or go to
everydollar.com and get started right
now spread the word we're here to help
whether you were meant or not we're here
and we're can help help you you want to
get control your freaking money this
budget app will do it for you it's
called every dollar you'll know where
every dollar is going Derek's in Dallas
hi Derek what's up yes sir so my wife
has a question um where we've taken
she's at work right now okay she we we
took FPU we've got everything listed out
from smallest the largest we've knocked
out some debt already with with the
bonus that I got she gets a 10e bon
bonus in
January uh she's got seven school loans
here about 19,000 worth and her her
question is for peace of
mind the the credit cards are a lower
balance so theoretically going by the
program we'd have to hit the school
loans but if if we I'm sorry you said
the credit cards are a lower balance you
me the school loans are lower
balance no the school loans are are
larger balances but but lower monthly
payments
and if if we did it according to FPU we
we do the school loans before the credit
cards but did the credit no credit card
no whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you must
have flunked you said you just told me
the the balances on the credit cards are
smaller uh yes okay you're supposed to
pay off smallest to largest not payment
balance there is there's two school
loans that are larger than or smaller
than and the the credit card okay so
what the question is if we pay off the
the larger balance on the credit card to
get up to free up a larger monthly
payment to go towards other things
versus if I pay off two credit cards it
frees up about
1171 can I be smart for a second go
ahead go ahead if you had a plan it got
you where you
are why would you question this why
don't you just do it we've taught 10
million people how to do
this well why are you trying to be a
genius now I'm not she's just wanting
the the snowball to be bigger she's
wanting the snowball to be working her
way it doesn't work her
way I gotta pay off the smallest to the
largest I got you all kinds of Studies
have backed up that what we're doing
actually works
including 10 million people of going
through Financial Peace University and
getting out of debt yes sir yes sir so I
agree okay I'll get past the smart like
and I'll calm down a second now let's
try a second let's go back at it for a
second so the do you need to be do we
need to walk through reinforcement on
why we teach that did you not you all
didn't grasp that from Financial Peace
University no we we understood it it was
just a question that she wanted more
reass and she she's a government
official so she was out a lot of the
classes and I was the one that was
attending so uh just because required
meetings that she had to attend so okay
so she like missed the class yeah he
does need reinforcement Dave Derek it's
okay to admit it you need the
reinforcement to be able to answer the
question no no no no no she needs to go
through that lesson well that's true
that's the answer that's true because
she wants a logical understanding and
because she doesn't have this knowledge
base that you've got that's okay that
makes more since then I went to class
and I disagree while I'm broke yeah no
we we don't disagree it was just no not
we
her okay okay cuz she was the one asking
the question she's not here but but she
now I can defend her because she has an
honest question about something because
she doesn't know she didn't go to that
she didn't go to that lesson right
correct okay cool that's fine I
completely I completely understand that
so let's go back then and uh instead of
picking on
her um because she's not here that's not
fair but
um we can do one of two things all right
let's do number one uh when did you take
the
class uh it was started few months ago
we just finished it up like three weeks
ago before or right after Thanksgiving
at your church or online at church yes
did you get the online application as a
part of the package that you guys got
into yes sir do you have access to the
the lesson to watch it uh yes sir okay
pull up the lesson on debt and the two
of you sit there and watch it and don't
you say a word let her let her catch up
with the knowledge base okay because
here now that that that'll help now but
then here's what for for your benefit at
this moment and the rest of the people
listening here here's what she's going
to hear for the first time and that is
this I
personally when I started this as a math
nerd wanted to pay off the highest
interest rate first which is
mathematically correct it's only
mathematically correct if you have the
same probability of
completion however when you pay off the
highest interest rate first or you start
monking around with paying off balances
that feel good you don't have the same
probability of completing the whole get
out of debt plan and when you enter
probability into the mathematics because
you messed with the behavior tool then
you you you you lower your completion
rate and all that Garb go to say if you
don't go get out of debt because you
screw with the plan then your plan was
dumb you know that's what it amounts to
so what what we've proven is is that
personal finance is 80% Behavior it's
only 20% head knowledge it's not a math
problem if we were doing math we
wouldn't have gotten in credit card Deb
it's not a math problem it's a behavior
problem so the way you attack a behavior
problem is with a behavior-based
solution not a math-based solution
that's what we started doing 30 years
ago and it's been highly successful
that's why I was leaning back in and
being a smart elic Okay uh but I didn't
understand at the moment that I did that
that your wife hadn't even seen the
lesson so bad on me so uh anyway now so
the way we what we know is is that if
you go to the gym and you work out and
you eat salads for a week and you gain 4
lbs you will
quit even if it would work a month from
now you won't keep doing it so your
probability of completion is zero you
have human beings have to have a sense
of traction we have to have some
solutions we have to have a sense of
progress a feedback loop psychologists
call it and we need a feedback loop that
says you're winning if I go the gym and
I lose weight I'll keep going to gym if
I quit eating Big Max and I lose weight
I'll quit eating Big Mac you will keep
in the loop if you pay off some debt
you'll pay off some debt you'll pay off
some debt you'll stay in the food back
Loop that's why the debt snowball works
and that's why it's been more successful
than any other get out of Deb plan in
America this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of today 2 Timothy 2:15 do
your best to present yourself to God is
one approved a worker who does not need
to be ashamed and who correctly handles
the word of Truth Steve maraboli says
Hustle until your haters ask if you're
hiring I like that that's pretty good oh
I don't know how many years that is I've
been doing it 30 and I got a couple of
them but uh I did I I did have have done
that in in this in this business within
a couple of Industries but uh I don't
know if we overall got we definitely
don't have all the haters asking if
we're but the you know the fun about
that the principle of that is true about
your show the early journeys of your
show you know where you just kept
hustling you kept adding stations and
then people started going oh I talking
about that in the radio business just
the other day with a bunch of radio
execs we were laughing about the old
days and naming names about this guy
wouldn't even take my call this guy was
a jerk and then later actually hired him
as a consultant exactly you know two or
three of them as a matter of fact but um
yeah we that that that is true about
that but the uh not public haters but
more like industry haters public haters
are public haters are trolls that's
different yeah that's a different thing
but that's very interesting well merry
Christmas everybody we're so glad you're
here Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is
my co-host today Edward is in Tampa
Florida hi Edward how are
you hi Dave hey hi the question I have
today is um I'm kind of struggling with
coming up with a plan of attack here of
how to pay off my mortgage while I'm
planning for
retirement okay are you out of debt
except your
mortgage yes good what do you
make um we have a household income of
about 240,000
sweet okay and uh what do you ow in your
house uh we owe uh
535,000 how old are
you 62
okay um if you're W to do this tomorrow
that's a struggle but what we teach is
true yeah 15% of your income towards
retirement and anything else in the
budget that you want to squeeze out
throw towards the
house yeah we've got about uh $300,000
of equity in the house yeah
um and I'm currently putting
in well 16% of my income into the 401K
because I'm taking advantage of the uh
the makeup payment you know increase of
the okay of the of the limit all right
are you putting anything else in a year
in that what's that is that all you're
putting into
retirement uh yes okay so you're at 16%
I said 15% whoopy okay so that's like 40
grand out of
250 so okay you got 200,000 bucks left
to live on and pay down your mortgage
how much you're going to pay down your
mortgage out of 200 Grand
okay well I got the uh
the current mortgage
is 2,300 no your balance is
what balance is 535 okay and you make
240,000 we have established you're
putting 40,000 of that into retirement
which leaves you 200,000 to do
everything else with pay some taxes
obviously you're obviously going to pay
the current mortgage pay payment and
then you should have what 50 60 70,000
bucks more 880,000 bucks more if you
watch what you're doing to throw at the
mortgage but you're not going to be able
to cruise on the Mediterranean three
months a summer and do
that right right I mean there are
definitely some Behavior changes that I
think we I need to make okay so Edward
let's put a real number on this when do
you want to have the house paid
off well the original goal was to have
it paid off by the time I retired so
that I could walk into retirement with
no when is
that well it was 65 okay that's three
years into 500 is 150 a year you're not
going to make that what can you put
towards this house realistically you
have any money other than retirement
saved you have other
Investments I have a few other
Investments small they're
not I've got $34,000 in cash in
emergency
fund um okay and then I've got about
another uh 15,000 20,000 in uh in
Investments okay so how long you've been
making
250 uh quite a few years okay so you
guys are spending a
lot yeah we're spending a lot yeah okay
so you got to decide okay so it's a big
math just take 500 and divide it by the
number of years you want to
work that's what I was trying to get to
you know if you div by 10 more years
instead of three more if you divide it
by 10 more years it's 50 Grand a year if
you divide it by you know what are we
going to divide it by I could work to
67 okay so that's five years that's
100,000 a year that's doable but that's
going to be a pretty dramatic cut in
lifestyle because we've established
you've been spending about $200,000 a
year so Lifestyles get if you want the
house paid off in five years you you
need 100,000 a year right 500 divided by
5 right right yeah so um and you make
250 we're putting 40 in retirement how
much is in your 401k
now uh 840,000 that's good news okay all
right so and when I looked at the the
the projection but by the time 65 it
would be I Bean 1.2 and by the time 67
would be 1.5 yeah if it's if it's
invested in
good mutual funds it should double about
every seven I me 12
yeah yeah now would it be better though
to stay where I am and and like you said
just eat eat beans and rice what house
do you want to retire
in or would it be better to downsize and
and and a move what house do you want to
retire in
right right you know here's the tradeoff
the trade-off is you're going to cut
lifestyle and put 100,000 on this for
the next five years up to 67 and you're
going to cut lifestyle or you're going
to move down so you don't have to cut
off lifestyle but you're going to live
in a smaller house all the way through
the your retirement
years right that's your
tradeoff putting what you're putting in
retirement is not what's killing you
what's killing you what's messing up
your math is your spending you're your
lifestyle and that's okay but you know I
agree with you that you need a goal of
by the time you hang up the cleats the
house is paid off that is a real goal
that's a solid one so 67
69 you know these are all things that
can go back and forth but you know and
you're okay with retirement Nest Egg
your retirement Nest EG is going to be
okay but I do need to clean this
stinking house mess up and it's a
tradeoff on what y'all are spending and
I don't know what you're spending it on
so I think that's a discussion you and
your spouse are going to have do we want
this house into retirement or do we want
this
lifestyle into retirement that's the
question and then if you take care of
that you're going to be sitting with
approximately a $2
million net worth or bet probably a $3
million net worth at
6769 you'll be able to do anything you
want the rest of your life but you got
to make some solid decisions for the
next 5 to seven years
mathematically and and it could be a
move down you may say we like our life
I'm not touching our life we would
rather we would trade that for a smaller
house that's a that's an okay trade if
you want to do that that's okay that's
what I would do if I were in their
situation I'd go a little bit smaller
and you'd rather buy the experiences
than the house I would I'd rather travel
eat good food do fun things with people
that I love and enjoy being around that
to me matters more than the the sweet
awesome huge house fine dining is a
wonderful sport I know you know I mean
no kidding but I mean he's already a
millionaire yeah he's doing great on
that he's making a quarter million a
year so you're you know not a stupid guy
you're doing great work you've done
Great Edward congratulations but if you
want to have what you're asking for is a
good goal yeah you're as you're
suggesting smart goals and I'm just
trying to help you get there and it's
just a math trade out it's there's
always opportunity cost on this if I do
this it means I can't do that if I do
that it means I can't do this so you
just whichever one it's okay um and both
are probably going to entail not
65 yeah that that's probably the case
all the way around that puts us hour the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
n